[Music]
maybe it's a pill
or a spray a liquid medicine
an easy and safe treatment to target
sarskoff ii
it would be given immediately after
diagnosis ideally it's available over
the counter in a pharmacy
a cheap antiviral tablet with bearable
side effects
we have vaccines we even have drugs that
help with the most
serious symptoms of kovid19 in the hunt
for a drug scientists are exploring many
different treatments
but where are we in the search for a
pill
good question welcome to our kobe 19
special i'm monica jones and berlin good
to have you with us
and wouldn't it be wonderful if we could
just
pop a pill in kobe 19 would be nothing
more than a nasty cold
science is working on a variety of
therapies but it's
somewhat slow going
how do you switch off the coronavirus
render it harmless
german scientists at co-rot therapeutics
set themselves this task a year ago
12 months later they seem to have
achieved their goal
mice medical mentally most drugs
currently in development target mild
cases of covet 19 illnesses
our drug is specially designed to cure
serious illnesses
their research and initial clinical
tests which have been running for a few
days
were primarily financed by private
investors in government funding from the
state of lower saxony
now the company needs more funding
of course we want to be ready to meet
market needs and our goal is to get the
emergency approval by the end of the
year
then we would have to produce in
sufficient scale that we can supply
patients with the necessary medication
currently the german government offers
funding of 50 million euros which is
split between several companies
this compares with over 740 million
euros in funding for vaccine research
we need tens of thousands of volunteers
for testing that's what costs a lot of
money and where you simply need larger
sums
when you vaccinate healthy people you
need a lot more healthy people than when
you are testing a drug that is targeted
at the sick einstein
recently however the federal government
appears to have re-thought the issue
and further funds have already been
announced
we lost many many months because the
financial resources were simply not
available for the drug developers
we can no longer afford to keep wasting
time
therapeutics says it needs 50 million
euros to reach the emergency approval
stage
german government funds won't be enough
for this so the biotech startup has been
speaking to international
investors now antiviral treatments
attack the virus and stop it
multiplying but the virus doesn't fight
fair
using our own cells to reproduce and
finding a treatment
is difficult at the best of times let
alone during a pandemic
[Music]
so far the only antiviral drug approved
for the treatment of coven 19 in germany
is rem deservier studies show a 33
reduction in the duration of the illness
there are other treatments being
developed
american pharmaceutical giant merck is
working on a similar drug called
monopyravir
and pfizer has also started human tests
on an antiviral drug
if the immune system overreacts in a
later phase of the disease
steroids such as dexamethasone come into
play
it's a cortisone that curbs the immune
system
in germany too dexamethasone is used in
severe cases
that is when the patient receives
additional oxygen
there are also preparations for antibody
treatment which helps prevent
symptomatic infection
the drug from us pharma giant regeneron
helped former u.s president donald trump
antibodies are also found in the blood
plasma of recovered covet 19 patients
their effect depends on the severity of
the illness and how long ago it was
germany's public health body the robert
[ __ ] institute
says deployment in severe cases is
possible
is a senior id physician at the
department of infectious diseases and
respiratory medicines at
charity university in berlin so very
good to have you with us especially
because
you are now offering the use of
monoclonal
antibodies in short mab or mab
in the so-called cove map outpatient
clinic in berlin
what exactly does this therapy offer
well we offer treatment with
one of the two available monoclonal
antibody products
these monoclonal antibodies
target the s-protein of the
sars cough ii virus and
they have a potential to prevent
the progression to severe disease
and elevate symptoms and yeah
limit the progression in patients with
mild to
moderate covet disease
particularly we know that in those who
have not developed yet an
endogenous antibody response we know
that
there is potential that these patients
benefit from this kind of therapy
and who are these patients that are
actually eligible to benefit from it
is it available to everyone
well um there are some criteria which we
look at
to find in the right patients
we look for patients who
have a new positive test so we
need a test
pcr result which is not older than 72
hours
to provide
security that we only treat patients in
the early course of infection
and we look for certain risk factors in
the patients
which are for example age or
immuno suppression for example
patients who are on active chemotherapy
because of
cancer patients who
are organ transplant patients and
therefore on immunosuppression are
candidates
for the treatment other patients for
example who have received
a medication which is called retoximab
patients
who suffer of aids are candidates
people with down syndrome are
patients kidney failure patients
patients on chronic hemodialysis
patients with obesity with a severe
elevated body mass index over 35
for example and you probably have to you
probably
you probably need to go to your own gp
and basically prove that you
are one of those patients who who
actually can get
this kind of treatment but could this
therapy also help prevent
an infection
well there are some preliminary
results showing that it could prevent
infection but the results from
randomized controlled
trials are not published yet so we do
not use it
as a prevention let's say as a
post-exposure prophylaxis when you
assume
infection so we so far only use it for
patients with a proven infection
which we use the pcr result for
now of course i have to remind you that
we're all dreaming
of a simple cure as we said at the
beginning of the program a pill
a spray something like that to help us
through an infection
uh how realistic is that notion
oh well of course that's what we all
dream of
so far we do not really have anything
really close coming up closely
for example just a pill of course
there's still trials going on
and we're looking for treatment options
but so far
there is no serious single
pill for example which we can
hope to be the future easy treatment
and everybody says the one way to really
fight this
pandemic is vaccination and once
enough people are vaccinated to reach
what we call herd immunity
do we actually still need therapy
good question um
sure i think we will always need
treatment options
um of course we always have to monitor
the
um the virus if we
look for antiviral treatment options
um there might be some change in the
virus itself like right now what is
going on with the variants occurring
this means that some of the antiviral
options might not work anymore
and then on the other hand we also have
the anti-inflammatory
treatment options but um so far most of
them are still under investigation so
we're still
hoping to find a good treatment and i
think we will always need a treatment
to come back to your question even
though if the
vaccination strategies will be
more rolled out and we have a higher
percentage of population to be
vaccinated we will always
probably face some
infections and some of them will need
treatment as well so
yeah it's uh i think always something
what we will
infinitely and definitely worth
investigating further than dr stigemann
from the charity in berlin thank you so
much
thank you
let's get back now to the root of our
troubles and that of course is the virus
and its variants
time to hand over to derek
is it possible that the same variants
arose independently without travel
in different places
the answer to this touches on one of my
favorite
evolutionary concepts called convergence
it's basically the idea that when
different species
face similar environmental pressures in
different places
then nature can come up with remarkably
similar solutions to cope with them a
good example of convergence is for
instance
the the protective spines that are
embedded
in the skin of both porcupines and
hedgehogs
the trait didn't arise just once in a
common ancestor and then get
passed down it evolved independently
in both species because a spiny
outside is clearly a good defense
against predators if you're
small and slow and just want to be left
in peace
to eat your leaves and insects viral
genomes also change constantly and it
happens a lot faster
than with animals because viruses
replicate so quickly
and abundantly the vast majority of
those changes
will be neutral or or even harmful but a
tiny number of them
will give a virus an advantage for
example
a mutated gene might change the spike
proteins
on its surface in ways that allow the
virus to slip into cells
more easily and because the saris cov2
genome is
is actually pretty small the chances
of specific identical mutations like
that occurring
in different places at different times
is actually fairly high
so we are seeing some of this sort of
genetic convergence but because variants
also collect many other highly
individual mutations as they evolve
genetic sequencing still allows us to
tell them apart
[Music]
derek williams there and he'll be back
again tomorrow to answer more of your
questions just
post them on our cov19 youtube channel
for now that's all for this edition of
our kobe 19 special thanks for watching